did you all file the papers for her
Green Card already no
wait pause you've never filed papers for
yourself to change the status that's
what it is he's saying they didn't do
that
she doesn't have a status she doesn't
have anything
wait you've never filed to adjust your
papers
I don't know what he said no goodness
why you say no we did
what does it mean
can you explain
Michael please talk
never uh
have that stage for adjust for her
status so yeah literally she has no
paperwork right now
what can I do
and the teacher is not mine I'm not a
toy he cannot bring me into another
country make me to survive here and have
to send me back I'm not a toy you can't
do this to me
I hope you find someone Natalie that
makes you happy and you know you have a
great family and everything else I'm 37.
it's yours because I gave you four years
of my life and I left you without even
taking my clothes
but you don't love him
she don't love me
we got married and you were gone in six
months Natalie I took you to my job
right
you made your bed now you got to lay in
it
I wasn't a priority for you
I I just want you to know
I did all I could
honestly
okay I have no I have no ill feelings
against you okay I will always have a
spot in my heart for you it didn't work
out it didn't work out you live in a
completely different state
we're not together no more
I'm terribly sorry
it's time it's time
I spent a whole year since you've been
home
I'm crying
[Music]
foreign